Das Podcast UFO, das Podcast UFO, das Podcast, Podcast, Podcast UFO mit dem Florentin, mit dem Florentin, mit dem Florentin und Stefan Tietz. Das Podcast UFO, das Podcast UFO, das Podcast, Podcast, Podcast UFO mit dem Stefan Tietz, mit dem Stefan Tietz, mit dem Stefan Tietz und Florentin. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von, ja, genau, das Podcast UFO. Muss man jetzt auch nicht mehr erwähnen. Das glaube ich haben wir oft genug gesagt. Folge 409, vielen, vielen Dank an Svenja, die hier mal ihr Piano bemüht hat, endlich lohnt sich's. Vielen Dank Svenja, vielen Dank auch an dich fürs erneute Erscheinen. Ja, ich bin da. Florentin Will. Ich habe tatsächlich, Flurwalzer konnte ich auch mal spielen auf dem Klavier. Flurwalzer, Continent Trédet von Amelie, habe ich auch im Repertoire gehabt. Das war mein gesamtes Repertoire. Ich hasse alle Menschen, die ein Instrument so halb beherrschen.
Ja, furchtbar. Wirklich, weil die spielen alle ...
Ich hasse mich selbst, wirklich, ich hasse mich selbst dafür.
Ja, du immer mit deiner Mondschein-Dreckssonate, dann mit deinem Drecks-Amelie, fucking Idiot, Arschlochkind, Amelie, dann Drecks-Bethofen und man spielt dann alle immer The River Flows fucking in you, fickt euch alle mit euren Fick-Songs und dann das gleiche mit scheiss Gitarre, Stairway to Fucking Bullshit Heaven, alle singen immer Wonder Fucking Wall, alle spielen die gleichen Kack-Songs. Tipp, wenn ihr noch irgendwen beeindrucken wollt mit anfänglichen Gitarren-Skills oder Piano-Skills oder whatever, spielt einfach irgendeinen anderen Song. Es gibt ja nicht nur drei Songs. Ich kann mich noch sehr genau an meinen Gitarrenlehrer erinnern, der da glaube ich keinen Bock drauf hatte und deswegen den achtjährigen Kindern irgendwie Prelude 1 von Fernando Carulli und Francisco Tadega gelernt hat. Und ich kann mich noch gut erinnern, als dann irgendwann so diese Jugendphase begann und diese barocke Musik jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr ganz meinen persönlichen Geschmack getroffen hat, wie noch im Alter von neun Jahren, und ich irgendwann mal ihm wirklich gesagt habe, ich würde mal auch selber gerne ein Lied mitbringen, das ich gerne spielen möchte. Und er so, ja klar, natürlich, gerne, gerne. Denkt natürlich irgendwie an die vier Jahreszeiten.
Carlo Colucci's Gabott.
Genau, Juan Busch-Galias, ungarischer Tanz oder so. Und dann sage ich ja, ja, it's the way to heaven. Und ich habe wirklich in den Augen einfach, ist wirklich eine komplette komplette Welt zusammengebrochen. Aber auch in mir wäre eine Welt zusammengebrochen. Die Berliner Mauerfeld, der Jenga-Turm, der Turm von Pisa gibt endlich auf, es ist alles stürzt und es ist so. Und er bleibt so, es ist was noch schlimmer als ein offener, zu Schau gestellter Unmut, sondern dann dieses, er grinst dann so, nimmt dann so seine Gitarre und nimmt dann so eine Zange und schneidet so grinsend, während so die Tränen runterläuft, die einzelnen Sait. Und dann nimmt er die Gitarre so. Und dann so das Abgestrochene, das ist jetzt so diese, weiss ich, was für ein Holz, das Mahagoni-Holz, sehr scharfes Holz, sehr spitzes Holz, nimmt das so und rammt sich so in den Hals. Und du bist komplett verstört. Blutspritze auf dich, dann kommst du nach Hause und deine Mutter, wasian, was ist passiert, was ist passiert? Und du sagst, ich habe Stairway to Heaven mitgebracht, im Gitarrenunterricht. Und dann grinst sie so und nimmt sich so ein Messer. Nein, aber ich verstehe den Gitarrenlehrer tatsächlich sehr. Absolut, und das ist wirklich ganz, ganz grauenhaft, weil ich glaube, der hat auch aktiv versucht, klassische Musik den Schülern näher zu bringen und wirklich all das, aber du kommst halt nicht gegen die Pubertät irgendwann an, glaube ich so. Selbst die Begnadetsten sagen dann irgendwann, ich will jetzt nochmal mit Wonderwall irgendwie auch mal das eine oder andere Mädchen beeindrucken, damit da was geht. Weil das Problem sind ja nicht die Schüler, das Problem sind ja die Mädels, dass die Mädels halt so selten auf irgendwie Andantino ansteigen. Aber auf Stairway to Heaven? Da, nee, aber da muss man ansetzen. Die Mädels 2011, die Mädels 2011 wollten doch nicht fucking, die wollten doch nicht Stairway to Heaven hören. Wonderwall geht immer, Stefan, Wonderwall, Stairway to Heaven geht immer. Doch, das ist einfühlsam, das ist rockig, das ist was, da will ich sie hormonisch spriessen, das ist halt dann nicht so ganz Prelude zwei.
Aber da auch nochmal an alle Mädchen da draußen, öffnet doch gerne mal eure Ohren auch zu den klassischen Klängen der Schüler, die mit ihren Fingernägeln spielen. Ich glaub, du, ja, mit ihren langen Fingernägeln spielen.
Was wollt ihr von Jungs mit langen Fingernägeln und diesem Fussbänkchen und so einer geliehenen Gitarre, wo noch so draufsteht, städtische Musikschule Ebersberg vorne drauf und so ein Barcode, der so drüber laminiert ist, weil immer die Kirche abschnebeln? Ja, das muss heiß werden. Was wollt ihr von dem hören? Was wollt ihr von dem hören, damit ihr mit dem in die nächste Runde geht? So, und ich glaube, egal was du spielst, ob das ist Stary to Heaven, Fucking Pokerface von Lady Gaga oder an Dante. Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba Willst du auch mit mir schlafen oder? Das wird noch dreimal wiederholt. Hier steht ein Doppelpunkt am Ende der Taktle kommt. Und zwar habe ich letztens
mal, habe ich tatsächlich
nur so ein Alltagsgeräusch,
irgendwie so, ich glaube, so die Schiebetür von einem
Auto ging zu mit so einem
und ich so
My life is brilliant,
my life is pure,
I saw an angel,
of that I'm sure, she smiles wie inside, she was with another man. Ich war einfach wieder bei You're beautiful, it's true. Und dann kommt Brianna. Ich höre You're beautiful, it's true. I'm the DJ, I'm the DJ, I'm the DJ, na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na na Abschlussklasse hast du immer die gleichen, weil es gab ja eine Zeit in Viva, wo wirklich ausschliesslich Handywerbung lief und ich habe das so tief in meinem Kopf drin, dass ich wirklich bei My Beautiful It's True zack sofort höre den nächsten Song und es hat mich wirklich zerstört. Mir geht das so bei manchen Playlists, die ich hab, in die man zurückgeht, die nicht so viele Lieder drin haben. Und wenn man da vergisst, den Shuffle-Mode reinzumachen, weiß ich auch genau, ich hab immer nach und auch mit Shuffle-Mode habe ich nach jedem Song eine Erwartungshaltung, welcher jetzt kommt. Von daher, das kenne ich auch. Aber das ist so eine Früge, das ist wahrscheinlich super tief in dir drin. Das ist richtig tief in mir drin. Wie viel Kram man sich merkt, das Gehirn, was komplett unnütz ist. Weil vielleicht checkt das Gehirn ja gar nicht, dass das zwei unterschiedliche Songs sind. Das Gehirn denkt, okay, das ist halt ein Song, das hat man so oft gehört, dass man denkt, James Blunt featuring Rihanna. So für uns Menschen ist das Quatsch, aber für das Gehirn sagt, hä klar, natürlich machen die ein Feature, warum nicht Rihanna, warum soll die nicht mit James Blunt zusammen einen Song machen? Und ganz unterschiedliche Musikarten. Aber das ist echt, wo ich mir echt dachte, ich bin einfach kaputt, ich bin einfach kaputt. Aber ich hatte früher ja auch Gitarrenunterricht und habe auch genau wie du genau diese oft ja spanischen, klassischen Gitarrensongs gelernt. Und dann auch super gemein hat mir der Gitarrenlehrer irgendwann mal einen Song gegeben fürs Vorspiel mit Gesang. What? Oh, und das war alles horrormässig. Vor allem das passt ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht zu dem klassischen Gitarrenspieler, oder? Doch, ein Gitarrestück und dann mit Gesang. Und du musst selber auch singen? Ja, horrific. Was war es, Olli Schulz? Nein, diese, ich weiß nicht mehr, so ein uraltes deutsches Volkslied. Ah, geil. Aber es war so eklig. Naja, und dann irgendwann habe ich keine Lust mehr gehabt, aus diesen Gründen, auch weil ich immer Angst hatte vor diesem Vorspiel. Und dann habe ich angefangen in einer Band zu spielen und habe dann daher Bass gespielt. Dann habe ich in der Musikschule auch Bassunterricht genommen. Und das war, da habe ich dann, das ist ja das Coole am E-Bass, wenn man das lernt, spanische, alte, klassische Songs sind keine Option, weil sie wurden selten für einen vierseitigen Bass geschrieben. Deswegen habe ich da dann aus einem ganz speziellen Grund nur Abba-Songs gelernt, weil nämlich die Musikschule irgendwie so einen Abba-Abend hatte und eine LivebandBand sollte dann die Abba-Songs spielen. Ich glaube, die haben einfach den Film Mamma Mia quasi chronologisch in den Songs nachgesungen und die wollten eine Live-Band haben, die Abba spielt. Und für diesen Abend habe ich alle Abba-Songs gelernt. Und es hat so viel Spaß gemacht. Erst dachte ich mir so ich bin jetzt nicht von andante
allegro weggegangen um jetzt hier beim e-bass spielen aber songs zu lernen aber ehrlich gesagt
hatte ich die beste zeit ich fand das so cool das ist auch coole musikalisch coole harmonien und
so ein scheiß und dann war ich aber krank an dem abend und hat ein anderer was ist das übernommen
dann hat es einen bassist übernommen der der das nicht ein halbes Jahr lernen musste, sondern vom Blatt spielen konnte. Ich glaube sogar der Lehrer selbst. Das war richtig schlimm. Aber das ist ja eh das Problem, dass nicht notwendigerweise das Instrument, das du magst, auch passend ist für die Musik, die du magst. Musik, die man magst? Das ist ja auch ein Problem manchmal. Und ich bin da auch tatsächlich Purist, muss man sagen. Wenn ich dann mal irgendwie so auf YouTube unterwegs bin und sehe dann, ah, Mondscheinsonate auf Gitarre, denke ich mir, lern einfach ein anderes, du hast dich einfach verskillt, lern doch einfach ein anderes Instrument so. Klar, man kann das immer machen, Medleys Arrangements immer gerne dabei und da werde ich auch viel Hass dafür kriegen. Aber ich denke mir so, es geht ja nicht, also das
funktioniert ja auch nicht von den Tasten
und so, was da alles klingen muss und so.
Für mich, für mich. Aber ich habe überhaupt gar keine
Ahnung von Musik, was ich jetzt letzte Woche
auch wieder gemerkt habe, denn
ich habe, du kennst es ja wahrscheinlich,
du schaust ein YouTube-Video oder irgendwo und da
kommt ein Song, der Song.
Du hast den Song im Kopf
und du denkst, wow, das ist er, das ist er. Und erst denkst du dir, ja, Verleugnung, das ist er nicht. Aber dann, einen Tag später denkst du dir, doch, das war schon der Song. Und dann findest du ihn nicht wieder. Du weisst, du kannst dich nicht mehr genau an das Video erinnern, du weisst nicht, wo es war. Ach, der das, findest du, der hatte dann oft Lyrics?
Der hatte leichte Lyrics, aber jetzt nicht so, dass man danach googeln könnte.
Das ist oft hilfreich.
You belong to me, so ganz einfache Sachen.
Und dann suchst du und suchst du und suchst du und irgendwann gibst du den Song auf.
Aber dann, wenn du es am wenigsten erwartest und du wieder durch das achtzehnte,
ein Affe rutscht die Rutsche runter oder ein Kindfeld vom Baum Video schaust, da kommt er. Und dann denkst du dir, okay, jetzt meine Chance. Jetzt habe ich ihn. Du hast ihn an der Angel, du hast ihn am Haken und du schaust in die Kommentare, was ist es und dann findest du einen Kommentar, wo jemand gefragt hat, what's the song, und es hat aber niemand geantwortet. Das hat niemand geantwortet, aber du weisst, da sind Leute auf der Suche. Das ist das Schlimmste.
Du weisst dich genau hin und her und du schaust wo es ist und irgendwann tatsächlich findest du diesen Song und ich dachte mir jetzt hab ich ihn, geb ihn ein auf YouTube, find den Song, hör ihn an es ist Ambrosia für die Ohren und du denkst dir, endlich Ambrosia von Rihanna endlich bin ich am Ziel und du denkst dir, geil, was ist das für eine Band? Das ist ja jetzt meine Band, die wird ja noch weitere Songs gemacht haben, die so ähnlich klingen, die so weiter sind. Und ich schaue auf den YouTube-Kanal und ich haue dir ins Gesicht. Und ich schaue, wie die Band heisst, Creative Commons Music. Nein! Du hast ganz am Anfang, als wir uns kennengelernt haben, das ist so spannend, hast du gesagt, ich habe einen sehr schlechten Musikgeschmack. Und ich habe darüber gelacht und gesagt, niemand hat einen schlechten Musikgeschmack. Du hörst einfach spezielle Sachen und du hörst einfach, was du gerne hörst. Das ist ja unfassbar. Heute ist offiziell bewiesen, du hast den schlechtesten schlechtesten musikgeschmack ich dachte mir wirklich das kann doch nicht wahr sein die selbst nicht mal die dies machen gut finden unlizenzierte musik das ist nämlich von den leuten die es rausbringen wahrscheinlich so dinge die hinten übergefallen sind diese nicht mehr brauchen ja dinge die die künstler innen mögen würden die einfach rausbringen dann als dann als Songs. Das heißt, selbst die haben es gehasst. Und die haben es dann als Creative Commons und du sagst, what is this, beautiful sounds. Und es ist wahrscheinlich auch von dem ursprünglichen YouTube-Video-Macher einfach so vorgeschlagen vom Algorithmus so, oder so direkt kostenlos, nimm das so, wo muss ich nichts zahlen, rein. Und für mich war das wirklich der Song für einige Tage. Und jetzt habe ich ihn, aber ich fühle mich jetzt auch ein bisschen schmutzig so du denkst dir das ist das ist so wie wenn dein lieblingsessen der mac chicken ist das ist so einfach das ist es ja aber ich habe den song jetzt ich habe ihn jetzt und höre ihn gerne und freunde mich jetzt auch einfach damit an dass ich ich einfach keinen Musikgeschmack habe und einfach das, was ja perfekt.
Das ist wie wenn du so dir einen Bilderrahmen kaufst und das Bild, was im Baumarkt im Bilderrahmen ist, das ist das schönste Bild, das du je gesehen hast.
Das ist dein Lieblingsbild.
Ich machte auch mal einen Song und dann kam raus, dass das der häufigste Song ist, der bei YouTube, ist auch ein Creative Song gewesen, und zwar der, der hieß irgendwie 001 irgendwas. Nee, nicht der. Das ist der? Das ist mein Lieblingsteil. Nee, der hieß dann irgendwie 001 irgendwas und die Band heisst 001 something. Standard. Und dann war das die erste Band, die vorgeschlagen wurde, wenn du auswählen konntest, Musik zuklicken und dann gab es so eine YouTube Library und das war einfach der erste Song, der vorgeschlagen wurde, weil die Band so hieß. Und der Song wurde so oft genommen und den mochte ich so gern. Ich mag den, aber ich reiche den nochmal nach. Aber es ist sehr lustig, es ist sehr schwer, Musik zu finden und es war sehr lustig, weil in Kolumbien, als wir diese Reise gemacht haben durch den Dschungel, sind wir sehr lange mit den Jeeps dahin gefahren zu diesem Ort, wo dann die Wanderung losging in den Dschungel.
Und das war irgendwie so eine zwei Stunden lange Reise mit dem Jeep. Und da war irgendwie, haben sich eine kolumbianische Mutter und ihr Kind haben sich mitnehmen lassen. Die Die wollten irgendwie eh an den Ort, wo wir da abgesetzt wurden, wahrscheinlich weil die da gewohnt haben, und haben sich da mitnehmen lassen. Und die machen diese Reise wohl irgendwie öfter. Und der Sohn hatte die ganze Zeit sein Handy in der Hand und wollte irgendwie die Zeit totschlagen, war ein Kleinkind. Der war viel zu jung, um sich irgendwie dafür zu beschäftigen, mich selber zu beschäftigen, sondern hatte dann einfach dieses Handy in der Hand und offensichtlich, weil es gab keinen Empfang mehr, hatte nur ein einziges Video von Instagram Reels geladen. Heisst, er hatte nur, wie lange sind diese Videos, so 30 Sekunden hatte er, was geladen war. Und er hat ungelogen zwei stunden in stag dieses instagram ein instagram video geguckt und es war ein song im hintergrund lief ein song und wir haben uns alle unterhalten dann waren da irgendwie keine ahnung es waren super viele menschen aus verschiedenen ländern der welt unterhalten und irgendwann so ist es aufgefallen irgendwas ist komisch irgendwas loopt sich gerade und es ist aufgefallen, wir hören zu... Wir haben immer wieder die gleichen Gespräche geführt, immer wieder, wo kommst du her? Aus Deutschland und dann lief die ganze Zeit dieser Song Ich warb es immer noch im Kopf Und es war, die Sprache war nicht erkenntlich und irgendwann so, hör mal, es läuft doch die ganze Zeit schon der neue Zeit schon der gleiche Song und alle so, ja, stimmt, was ist das für ein Song? Und er fing immer an der gleichen Stelle an, hat immer gleichzeitig wieder an der gleichen Stelle aufgehört und es war irgendwas osteuropäisches, also sowas wie, keine Ahnung, Ungarisch oder sowas, komplett unidentifizierbar und so, das war eine der Top-10-Sprachen, die man so erkennt. Und wir haben den danach finden wollen. Und das einzige, was wir hatten noch, war die Beschreibung der Französin, die direkt neben ihm saß und uns erklärt hat, was das im Video passiert. Aha, was zu sehen war, ja. Und dann konnten wir mit dieser und ihre Beschreibung war, well there is the Kirby, it's some kind of Kirby character and it's getting pumped.
In der Linie. It's getting pumped, Kirby.
It's a little Kirby-Character and it's like, but he's like losing to somebody and then
he's like, he's going to the gym and getting very buff and pumped and it's a buff Kirby
and then he's fighting and he's winning. Aber er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist, er ist bei youtube reels gab es den dann haben wir in die gruppe gestellt dieser und diese gruppe stellt ja irgendwann ein das sind diese whatsapp gruppen die sich auf diesen reisen bilden dann schicken alle noch kurz irgendwie halb gar zwei fotos wo sie jetzt gerade nach der wanderung sind in kolumbien und dann hört nichts mehr und dann haben mein kumpel und ich das video reingestellt von buff kirby und die gruppe ist durchgedreht aber es war eine lustige Fahrt. Aber unfassbar, dass so ein Kind lieber sich 30 Sekunden immer wieder anschaut, anstatt aus dem Fenster zu schauen. Er kennt die Wälder, er kennt den Urwald. Aber ja, ich meine, ich kenne das ja gut mit so Magazinen oder Zeitschriften oder so, dass man dann so den Spielzeugkatalog von Karstadt oder so hatte, der halt dann im Auto war und immer stundenlang immer wieder die gleichen Bilder angeguckt hat gelesen ich kenne das ist halt weniger nervig für die Umstehenden aber das ist schon krass wie man sich da so rein versetzen kann und es dann auch das macht einen so wahnsinnig wenn man nichts versteht geht. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum diese kolumbianische Junge, erst dachte ich, ja, ich Spanisch, aber dann war es halt diese Sprache. Das war wirklich, das war ein Abenteuer. Und wir haben diesen Song auch nicht vergessen, der ist immer noch so in meinem Kopf. Ich glaube, wie bei dir auch. Wenn das jetzt genau der Song wäre, den ich gefunden habe, auch so. Das ist einfach so dieser magische Song, der alle in seinen Band zieht. Ich wundere mich eh, also die Idee hatte ich glaube ich schon in Folge vier oder so, warum es nicht sowas einfach wie ein Internetdetektal gibt, dass du einfach sagst, ich bin Internetdetektiv, ich finde Dinge im Internet und es gibt auch so viele Leute, die irgendwie so ein Video haben, Song haben, Porno haben, den sie irgendwie schon vor Jahren gesehen haben, nicht mehr finden. Das ist doch ein Geschäftsmodell, warum gibt es das nicht? Vor allem, du kannst es ja online einfach machen. Du schreibst einfach in so ein Formular alles, was du weißt, der Detektiv nimmt den Fall an und sobald er ihn gefunden hat, macht er dir einen Offer und sagt so, ich habe ihn gefunden, 20 Dollar und du kriegst den Link. ich lieb das und dann dann sagst du, ja klar, mache ich so. Und dann, wenn es nicht der richtige ist, naja, Pech gehabt so. Du musst halt gucken, wie es funktioniert. Oder dann kriegst du die Hälfte zurück oder so. Wir nennen diese App zum Beispiel, also nur jetzt, muss noch irgendwas kommen. Irgendwas, was zeigt, dass man was schnell finden kann und das ganze Internet so im Blick. Ich denke in eine ganz andere Richtung. Ich denke eher irgendwas, was von uns kommt. Also ich denke eher sowas, dass man sofort versteht, was es ist. Ich denke eher in die Richtung. Wo haben wir es gerade erfunden? Und wo kommt das jetzt her? Oder ist das Wann wirklich für den User? Man nennt es aber das Podcast-Uvo. Und das ist eine Website, auf der man einfach das eine Formular hat. Da kann man Dateien hochladen, Songs hochladen, Bilder hochladen, whatever. Und dann so ganz dumm, auch mit Sprachnachrichten, so. Genau. Kein Charme, keine Charme. No shame. And then there was a above Kirby and he was a training to be a better guy. Und genau so hast du dann die Möglichkeit, da was hochzuladen und dann der Indirektetitiv dann einfach so in so einem dunklen Raum.
Ich finde hier den Kolbe hier.
Da war er wieder.
Das Gespenst, dieses Lied, diese Rhythmen.
Ich habe ihn nicht zum ersten Mal gehört, nein, damals kam eine Frau in mein Büro.
Damals.
Sie roch nach Kirschblüten und Sünde. Das Blut in meinen Adern pumpte im gleichen Rhythmus, wie Kirby trainierte, und ich wusste, ja, ich werde mich aufpumpen müssen um diese Frau. Und da war er wieder dieser Song, ich muss ihn finden, irgendwo da draussen, in dieser Welt, die mich verschluckt, muss er sein, irgendwo da draußen. Und wenn ich daran zugrunde gehe, werde ich ihn finden. Ah nee, das ist doch der Ding hier von Abba. Ach ja, richtig, ja. Und dann, ich frage mich wirklich, warum es das nicht gibt, weil ich glaube, da könnte man wirklich Geschäft machen. Das Internet. Du musst es halt nur irgendwie finden. Ich will so einen Noir-Film mit diesen Lamellen-Jalousien. So mit der arche meinst du ach so da habe ich mir einen kleinen jungs erlaubt da muss ich jetzt kurz nachdenken und dann ist mir aufgefallen du ist ein wortspiel aus noir und noir und da habe ich kurz gebraucht ach du bist verrückt und dann zwei st Stunden lang nur auf dem Schiff. Wo sind die Giraffen? Wo sind die Giraffen? Jetzt, wenn eine Giraffe über Bord ist. Noah, hör mir zu, eine Giraffe ist über Bord gegangen. Ja. Warum sollen wir die andere ... Nein, Noah, ich dachte, es gibt ... Warum sollen wir die zweite Giraffe noch ... Kreuzung, Kreuzung. Nein. Der Elefant. Noah. Ich will ein Elefant mit einem langen Hals. Nein, stopp, Noah, so funktioniert das nicht. Ich will einen ... Elefanten mit einem langen Hals. Ich war jetzt nicht dabei, als Gott mit dir geredet hat, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das die ... Gott hat gesagt, er will ein Elefanten mit einem langen Hals. Du kannst jetzt nicht einfach sagen, dass er das behauptet hat. Das ist Quatsch. Wenn Gott einen Elefanten mit langen Hals wollte, dann würde er ihn so erschaffen. Ich will einen Affen mit einer Löwenmähne. Okay, gut. Wir probieren es nochmal. Dann kratzt Noah sich so am Kopf und hat so Frosch-Gecko-artige Schwimmhäute. Geckos haben diese kleinen Saugnäpfe an ihren Händen. Die sind sehr süss, weil die hängen überall fest. Und irgendwie ist das total genial, weil an jedwedem Material können die sich festhalten. Auch Material, wo sie nicht unbedingt, wo sie nicht so wirklich, als würde man sich daran festkleben können. Aber, also jetzt, können die klatschen? Nee, dann hängen sie niemals. Das ist wie so ein Paketband. Oh shit! Paketband ist ja so, klebt ja so schlecht, ausser an sich selbst. Paketband an sich selbst, wenn du das so umdrehst. Schöne Metapher. Schwierig, ja. Und dann auch, es kräuselt sich so direkt ein. Oh, Paketband. Ich habe versucht, jetzt ein Kabel zu verlegen, weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf WLAN. Ist das eine, ähm, oder für Sex? Okay. Und zwar, ich wollte ein Kabel verlegen, weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf WLAN. Nein. Aber auf Porn was heißt? Keinen Bock mehr auf WLAN. Wegen Porn. WLAN ist für mich eine gescheiterte Technologie und ich möchte sie begraben. Warum ist sie gescheitert für dich? Ich möchte ein großes Grab ausheben, sämtliche Router da reinwerfen und sagen, Router gut ist, fertig. Und bei mir ist es so ein bisschen blöd mit den Anschlüssen und so, da ist der Router in einem Raum und das Internet wird gebraucht im zweiten Raum. Jetzt sagst du Verstärker. Alles Bullshit, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Ich habe mir jetzt ein langes Kabel besorgt, das ist weiss und dünn und das lege ich jetzt einmal den Türrahmen hoch, dann an die Decke und an der Decke in durch den Flur entlang. Die Tür kannst du nicht zumachen mehr. Kannst du die Tür noch zumachen? Er ist relativ dünn und die Tür hat ja so ein Gummipolster. Das geht noch. Es ist ein bisschen zäh mittlerweile. So und dann durch. Und ein Loch durch die Wand war keine Option. Ganz furchtbar. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, bevor du das jetzt festmachst, nimm doch so diese praktischen Klebestreifen, die an beiden Seiten kleben. Diese Gummi-Patex-Print und Kleb, ruiniert dein ganzes fucking Leben und deine Tapete in einer Stunde, Dinger. Und das war so eine katastrophale Aktion am Ende des Tages, weil was ist passiert, und das ist wirklich kein Witz, ich habe diese Kabel hingeklebt, irgendwie ganz furchtbar, bin ich nachts, bin ich aufs Klo gegangen, habe nicht gemerkt, dass schon die Hälfte runtergefallen ist, das Kabel am Boden lag, ich ins Kabel und dadurch habe ich die anderen auch nicht runtergerissen, die halbe Tapete runtergerissen und dann dachte ich mir, jetzt nachts habe ich es dann wie rudimentär irgendwo hingeklebt, einfach nur aus dem Weg und am nächsten Morgen habe ich das wirklich gesehen und dachte mir einfach, Schande.
Er war es sehr wichtig. Jetzt nachts habe ich es dann rudimentär irgendwo hingeklebt, einfach nur aus dem Weg und am nächsten Morgen habe ich das ruhig gesehen und dachte mir einfach Schande, einfach Schande, Schande über mich, über dieses Monstrum, das ich geschaffen habe, absolute Katastrophe. Und wie sieht die Tabelle jetzt aus? Ist die abgerissen? Ganz furchtbar. Also Teile abgerissen und du reisst ja dann immer so tropfenförmige Dinger ab, wo das dann nochmal so ein bisschen runterreisst.
Das ist ja auch so ein Ding, wie weit reissen Dinge? Das ist ja immer so dieses Fingernagelding. Da hatten wir doch Wort für Pips.
Wie weit reissen Dinge? Zu wie weit reissen Dinge?
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, man hat so 20 Wände mit Material beklebt und oben ist so ein Riss angedutscht.
Und man muss vorher, muss ein Team aus Prominenten raten, wenn man einmal runterreißt, immer in der gleichen, es gibt einen Menschen, der es neutral immer runterreißt, in dem gleichen Tempo. Und es ist die Frage, wie lange reißt es ab, bis es in der Hand ist, als einständigem Ding. Ja, und dann, also wie markieren die das? Haben die so, ich denke jetzt an verschiedenfarbige Eddings? Wie meinst du markieren? Die müssen ja an der Wand markieren, bis wo es geht. Und der Promi, der am nächsten dran ist, hat dann gewonnen. Genau. Barbara Schöneberger hat dann so einen verschiedenen Stift, dann noch anderen irgendwie, Lena Mayland tut es dabei. Alle spenden das, was sie gewinnen, für einen guten Zweck. Für welchen Zweck? Einen guten Zweck, wie zum Beispiel ein Herz für Kinder. Das denke ich mir jedes Mal bei diesen verdammten Promi-Shows, wo es heißt Quiz und am Ende wird für eine wohltätige Organisation deiner Wahl geschenkt. Warum sagen die nicht, wofür die sich entscheiden? Meistens am Ende. Habe ich noch nie gesehen am Ende. Ah, Lena Weilandroth gewinnt 100.000 Euro. Lena Weilandroth lacht sich kaputt. 100.000, was soll ich damit? Was soll ich damit? Einen Bankschein bezahlen? Nee, Lena, Lena, es ist für einen guten Zweck, für einen guten Zweck. Ach so, deiner Wahl. Und dann soll Lena sagen, ja, für Luchse. Und das Publikum still. 100.000 Euro für Luchse. Ausser einer der Klatsch, und dann geht die Kamera so hin, es ist ein Luchs. Es ist ein Luchs im Publikum. Mit so ganz glänzenden Augen. Ich meine, es ist sogar ein krebskrankes Kind anwesend, das war Teil der Challenge. Und es wurde, und es war so, ja, okay, es war Teil, Boah! Boah! Hä? Nein, nein, wenn ich dich kriege! Ich finde, Kinder sind so lustig, es gibt ein Video vom, ich glaube, New York Philharmonics oder so was, die ein Konzert spielen, und im Publikum sass ein Kind offensichtlich, weil das Konzert
ist vorbei und es gibt
noch diesen Moment, wo der Dirigent hält noch so
die Spannung. Das Publikum schweigt noch,
es war eigentlich vorbei. Und dann nimmt er und dann
wird geklatscht. Aber das Kind checkt es nicht.
Die Spannungsorchester ist vorbei und man hört nur
so, es gibt die Aufnahme
und das Kind ruft, wow!
Orchester ist vorbei,
das Kind ruft, wow! Und die Leute fangen an zu lachen, weil es süss ist. Aber nervig, ne? Also bitte erzieht eure Kinder richtig, dass sie das nicht machen. Ja, dann war doch eine schöne Geschichte, weil das Kind war eigentlich autistisch, hat sehr wenig gesagt vorher. Und dann sagt sie natürlich, was das erste Wort war. Okay, dann kann man damit nicht rechnen. Ich spende trotzdem an die Luchse. Sie können ja Luchse spenden. Doch, am Ende muss der Promi dann noch sagen, ich spende an die Lena-Meyer-Landrut-Stiftung für gescheiterte Füchse. Für gescheiterte Popsängerin. Hey! Oh Mann, das stimmt doch nicht. Da kommt das Album bald. Christina Stürmer macht auch weiter. Christina Stürmer stürmt voran. Das macht jetzt ein MTV anplagt. Geil! Und ich war mit dem Auto durch Österreich gefahren, neulich, und da konnte ich den ganzen Tag, den ganzen Tag lief da ein Bericht mit, also ein Interview mit Christina Stürmer. Wie viel hat man zu sagen? Sie hatte so viel zu sagen. Aber ging es nur um sie und ihre Karriere oder auch generell einfach? Ja, ihre Karriere und MTV Unplugged, was sie jetzt aufnimmt und so. Und dann haben sie einen Song natürlich gespielt aus dem MTV Unplugged, Ich lebe. Und da habe ich gedacht, warum habe ich gerade einen Tag lang Christina Stürmer zugehört, wie sie über sich selber spricht. Und am Ende hat sie halt einen Song, sorry, aber am Ende hat sie einen Song. Ja. Und ihre, weißt du wie ihre Plattenfirma heisst, die sie jetzt neu gegründet hat? Das Gift, das du gewonnen hast? Nein, Ich lebe Productions oder sowas. Ach Gott, ey.
Aber da darf man sich dann auch nicht beschweren, wenn man auf diesen einen Song reduziert wird, finde ich.
Nein, sie tut alles dafür.
Sie tut alles dafür.
Und dann gehen Leute zu dem MTV anpluggt, um dann ich lebe zu.
Das Kabel, du bist das Kabel, doch es steckt nicht in mir drin.
So, ist das ein Vermittnis für Sex?
Florentin, du bist aber heute zotig unterwegs. Nein, nein, es ist anklagt. WLAN-Empfang, der ist nicht gut, ich kleb das Kabel, du bist die Wand, doch die Tapete reisst bis zum Boden runter. Die einzigen, die nicht abhusten müssen, sind Rocksängerinnen. Ja, das stimmt. Die brauchen das sogar. Hustet nicht ab. Die brauchen den Schleim. Die müssen sammeln. Und dieser Pingu-Sprecher. Glaubst du, bei Pingu, das habe ich mich letztens gefragt, Pingu ist ja dieser kleine Pinguinknete,, der immer nur so synchronisieren die wirklich jede Folge oder haben die einmal einfach, ey Udo, du gib mir mal so 30 Minuten oder auch so bei Animal Crossing, die machen doch nicht jede Cutscene und sagen, okay, in der Cutscene geht es darum, dass der Blumenladen, da gibt es jetzt Käfer, die in den Blumenladen gehen und die haben die Rosen zerfressen. Und jetzt geht es darum, dass du die Käfer, als Held sollst du die Käfer einfangen. Es gibt jetzt einen Dialog. Das ist so Behind the Scenes von Animal Crossing, dass so super krasse Schalspieler da stehen. Da stehen wirklich so Brad Pitt und Angelina Jolie in einem Raum. Komischerweise ist es ein bisschen ein schlechtes Beispiel, aber nur, keine Ahnung. Nur für euch, also Angelina, du bist die Blumenverkäuferin, du hast das Problem mit den Käfern und Brad Pitt, du hast einen Kescher, du musst die Käfer jetzt fangen als Quest in Animal Crossing, okay? Alles klar, dann würde ich sagen, take eins und bitte. Noch eine kurze Frage. Ja bitte, Brad. Kannst du mir ein bisschen was sagen zur Stimmung? Also woher komme ich? Was ist gerade so, wo komme ich her? Du bist ein kleiner Hund, ein menschengrosser Hund, du hast eine blaue Jacke. Ich will ja was beweisen, ich will ja meiner Mutter was beweisen wahrscheinlich. Du hast primär Schulden, also du hast finanzielle Schulden, deswegen bist du auf dieser Insel gefangen. Und du musst die Schulden abbezahlen durch so kleine Aufträge, für die
du Geld bekommst. Und diese Figur, Nuk Nuk,
hat mich hier eingesperrt quasi.
Naja, also es ist eine emotionale Erpressung,
aber vor allem finanziell hat er dich am
Haken. Okay. Aber es geht
jetzt eher darum, du bist eher der Neugierige.
Was ist hier los, wie kann ich helfen?
Du bist erstmal unbedarft. Okay, alles klar.
Gut, dann Take, alles klar.
Take zwei, bitte. Alles klar, haben wir. Super. Das machst du doch nicht, sondern du machst einfach einmal. Nimmst einmal auf und dann wird das einfach wieder reingeschnitten. Rasen-Cousins-Fäden. Bei, Bobati, den. Rasen, Tasen, Basen, Kasen, Resalve, Kataisen, As-Main. Wenn sich Amerikaner und Engländer, finde ich, fragen, wie ihre Sprache klingt für Leute, die es nicht sprechen, ist Simmsisch. Ja, absolut, Simlish. Simlish, ne? Rasen, Kataisen, Kasen, Basen, Kasumado, Hala, Kababidi, Gabalabudu, Gabalibi.
Fucking Fiebertraum. Stell dir vor, du willst Schauspieler werden, du hast die Schule absolviert, du kriegst einen Job, stehst im Tonstudio und dann hast du einfach so ein wirklich 400 Seiten dickes Skript mit Gabalubu Dabidal, Gababobu, Gielbidi Babu und du denkst dir einfach nur noch zwei. Diesen Seidenschalltragenden, Rauchenden, mit so einem alten Sakko, ist da so ein Regisseur hinten und sagt, du fühlst es nicht. Du fühlst es nicht. Du musst doch mal aufs Klo, verdammt. Du musst aufs Klo. Und bitte. Gababu-budu-digli-babab. Nein! Verdammt noch mal! Du willst dich aufs Klo. Deine Blasenleiste ist voll, die ist rot, ja? Okay, okay, okay. Verdammt noch mal! Ich versuch's noch mal, okay? Okay? Raisin, blasen, cousin, rise with cousin. Na, gib doch! Die war's! Weltklasse, der Junge! Ich bin so ein Schnitt. Es macht wahnsinnig Spaß, unter Angelo D'Arad arbeiten. Ich meine, wir arbeiten hier an Weltkultur. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Es geht um Weltkultur und es ist schön, dass ich als Schauspieler da meine Seele geben kann und mich selbst bewirklichen kann. Es war ein Projekt, das ich von Anfang an selber machen wollte. Also viel delegiere ich natürlich. Also der Name Angelo Dardini ist natürlich eine Marke, aber das wollte ich selber machen, weil bei Sims geht es ums Leben und ich glaube, das ist was, da kann jeder was dazu sagen, also das sind Dinge, mit denen beschäftige ich mich jeden Tag, ich muss auch aufs Klo gehen, ja, also ein Angelo Dettini muss auch schlafen, braucht auch Freunde und deswegen wollte ich das einfach, war das ein Schuss? Was, das ist ein Schuss aus der Tonkabine?
Doch das war schon zu spät. Als wir den Kameras in die Tonkabine kamen, haben wir den Schauspieler Thorsten Schubert nur noch tot aufgefunden. Ein tragischer Selbstmord.
Er hat unter dem Druck des Regisseurs nicht weiterleben wollen und hat sich bei dem Projekt das Leben genommen.
Seine Wohnung in Bonn ist bis heute unbewohnt.
Stets im Verkauf.
Stets.
Bitte melden Sie sich. www.immobilienscout.de
slash article 35 087.
Fragezeichen ist gleich A grosses x kleines p fdd in memoriam hier ein ausschnitt aus der beschreibung der wohnung helle wohnung licht durchflutet hier werden ihreohnträume wahr und die Herzen höher schlagen.
Ruhige Lage mit aktiven Nachbarn.
U-Bahn, Gott, mit kommunikativen Nachbarn, Jesus.
Die U-Bahn drei sowie vier und fünf sind in vier bis fünf Minuten Gehweg schnell zu erreichen. Fahren alle 20 Minuten, vergessen werden, deine Stimme heilt für immer im Äther der Unendlichkeit. Hier ein Zusammenschnitt von seinen grossen Momenten mit so einer Musik. Kababubu, Gabi Laba, Shibadu, Sibaduliga, Bailis Nathos, Billy Bamba, Rasenbasen-Kasen, Daryli, Daryli. Ende. Und damit haben wir tatsächlich Cannen gewonnen, also das Doku-Kan. Das war eine schöne Doku. Das kleine Doku-Kann. Ist natürlich schön, wenn da noch was passiert. Aber apropos Wohnung, meine Wohnung ist die absolute Hölle aktuell. Ich habe ja von dem Schimmelschaden erzählt. Hier in einem Blick in deinem Bildungsartikel. Verschimmelte Dreckswohnung. Verschimmelte Dreckskammer, die Hölle auf Erden. Lassen Sie sich in der Kölner Innenstadt schlecht gehen.
Wäre der Gestank nicht so unerträglich, würde man kaum übersehen, dass hier tatsächlich alles falsch läuft.
Das Positivste an der Wohnung sind die ruhigen Nachbarn rechts und links daneben, weil die hat noch niemand vorher gesehen und die halten sich auch zurück.
Die Fenster sind dreckig. Was ist passiert? Meine Wohnung, ähm, Wasserschaden komplett verschimmelt. Ja. Ich bin geflohen, ähm, war nicht mehr drin und dann hieß es, ja, da muss gestrichen werden und dann habe ich meinem Hausmeister den Schlüssel gegeben. Es klingt, als müsste mehr passieren, als nur gestrichen werden. Das habe ich mir auch gedacht, deswegen dachte ich mir, weil der Hausmeister meinte, ja, da warten wir einfach ein bisschen und dann wird das gestrichen. Hausmeister sind so pragmatisch. Fehlt nicht dieser Teil, wo das Problem behoben wird, bevor man die Fassade neu macht? Du meinst das Schimmelproblem. Fehlt da nicht ein essentieller Teil, dass das Wasser aus der Wand raus muss? Also dachte ich mir, nehme ich es selber in die Hand und kaufe mir einen Gebläse, so ein Heizgebläse. Und ich habe mir wirklich ein ordentliches Heizgebläse gekauft und habe das gegen die Wand gerichtet und habe dann so meinen Tag verbracht. Das ist zwar nicht deine Aufgabe. Nee, aber es ist meine Wohnung. Wenn es niemand macht, mache ich es. Mieterschutzbund, Mieterschutzbund. Ich mache das sehr. Okay, dagegen kann ich jetzt ledig nichts mehr sagen. Da setzt du mich einfach Schachmatt. Ich habe das selber gemacht. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich früh morgens dieses heisse Gebläse auf die Wand gerichtet und habe das wirklich ganz schäbig so mit Schuhen hingestellt, dass es genau auf diesen Schimmelfleck geht, weil es alles verschimmelt, aber da, wo es am schlimmsten war. Und dann war ich den ganzen Tag auf einem Dreh, der viel länger gedauert hat als gedacht, und ich dachte mir, ja, kann gut sein, dass einfach meine Wohnung abgebrannt ist in der Zwischenzeit, weil ich habe das auf volle Lotte heiß, mehr oder weniger direkt an die Wandtapete gestellt. Das ist ein Wunder, dass du noch lebst. Du lebst gefährlicher als jeder Sims, für den ich jemals verantwortlich war. Und so habe ich es vielleicht geschafft, noch ein paar oberflächlich zu trocknen, aber es ist ja absolute Katastrophe, also ein Wasserschaden, absolute Katastrophe, weil es geht ja auch überall hin, in alle Ecken, in andere Wände, taucht dann überall diese Schimmelflecken auf und dann hast du diesen merkwürdigen Orangenschimmel, den man dann auch, und du denkst immer so, ich muss das jetzt aber abwischen, aber dann wird es ja wieder nass und dann trocknen und hin und desinfizieren und Alkohol, alles stinkt nach Wodka, weil ich den überall, es ist absolut katastrophal. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte. Alles riecht nach Wodka, aber es ist egal, dass sie nicht hin, dass sie nicht mit der Schimmelsache zu tun. Und das war, ich wollte einen Barkeeper-Kurs gemacht, egal. So, und dann bin ich geflohen, hab dem Hausmeister den Schlüssel gegeben, weil der gesagt hat, ja, wir müssen noch warten, bis es trocken ist, und dann hieß es irgendwann, ja, jetzt wird gestrichen. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja, da hängen aber Regale alles und so. Und da steht mein ganzes Zeug rum. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, da kommen jetzt fremde Menschen in meine Wohnung, bauen alle Regale ab, ich war nicht da, und bauen alles ab. Wie kommen die eigentlich in diese Wohnung immer rein? Ich hab dem Schlüssel gegeben. Ich hab gesagt, mach das, weil will ja nicht dass die arbeiten während ich da bin also dachte mir wenn dann schon und dann hat also dieser gedanke langsam gedämmert die nehmen da die ganzen regale ab mit allem was drin ist in der küche mit allen meinen fertig suppen mit allen meinen möchte gern ich nehme jetzt mal ab pulver bullschiff vor allem du bist ja jemand der will du willst der gesellschaft Menschen, du willst die demnächst nicht auffallen oder hier jetzt schon ein komisches Beispiel, weil du literally Podcaster bist, aber so, du möchtest eigentlich der Gesellschaft nicht im Wege stehen. Absolut. Du hast grosse Angst davor, auf Rolltreppen in einer Innenstadt oder sowas im Weg zu stehen, du willst kein Ballast sein für die Welt, du willst ein bisschen People-Pleaser. Ja. In dem Sinne, dass du am liebsten sich unsichtbar auflöst. Genau, deswegen mache ich es auch selber mit dem Entlüften und sage nicht, ich trete irgendeinem Bund bei, sondern nee, ich mache es, okay, dann lasse ich halt das da laufen. Das muss ja die absolute Hölle für dich sein, zu wissen, dass Leute behindert durch deinen Kram an den Wänden da stehen, dein Kram aus den Regalen räumen müssen, die Regale abbauen müssen, um dann die Wälder zu sprechen. Ich weiß auch gar nicht,, was da alles drin war. Ich stopfst so halt irgendwas rein und absolut furchtbar. Und jetzt habe ich das so ein bisschen verdrängt einfach aus meinem Kopf. Ich bin nicht da, mir egal, was da in der Wohnung passiert. Und jetzt bin ich zurückgekommen. Aber es gab auch keine Absprache mit dir. Keine Absprache. Bitte machen Sie die Wände frei. Gar nichts. Überhaupt nicht. Da hieß so, ja, meine Leute machen das, meinte der Hausmeister. Meine Leute machen das. Meine Leute machen das. Und jetzt bin ich tatsächlich wieder in die Wohnung zurückgekommen und mein kompletter Hausrat, alles was ich besitze, steht jetzt im Wohnzimmer, weil die haben da die ganzen Wände alles neu gemacht und also mir ging es noch nie so schlecht, wirklich, es geht mir richtig schlecht, weil es ist so unangenehm, weil du siehst dein gesamtes Hab und Gut, das ist so wie wenn du den Browserverlauf deines Lebens sehen würdest.
Ausgedruckt, vor dir, von deinen Eltern hingelegt.
Was da alles ist, das ganze dumme Zeug steht da alles rum, alles was du besitzt, ein gesamtes Hab und Gut, wurde von irgendeinem Handwerker in die Hand genommen, beurteilt, die Ritterrüstung, Schwert, irgendwelche Sachen, dann ganz viele tüten suppen noch zu hause ganz ganz zeug alles richtig unangenehm und du siehst wirklich diesen lebenshaufen in deinem wohnzimmer kannst dich kaum bewegen überall nägel alles rum und es hat ein gesamtes leben wurde von fremden leuten mal in die hand genommen und irgendwo hingestellt bewertet auch natürlich natürlich. Bewertet, genau, bewertet, ausgelacht wahrscheinlich. Wissen wir nicht. Hingelegt und jetzt alles noch da und die haben wir auch die Türen ausgewechselt, alles komplett neue, Türen stehen auch noch rum, aber es ist halt nur halbfertig. Und jetzt lebe ich in einem absoluten Chaos einfach. Also alles da, ich komme gerade noch so zu meinem Bett, in der Dusche, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da duschen kann, ist alles alles abgenommen, alles umgebaut, alles auch super dreckig. Aber du zahlst ja Geld für diese Wohnung. Ganz, ganz schrecklich. Also an euch da draußen, weil ich weiss, das wirst du eh alles jetzt nicht dir zu Herzen nehmen, aber ihr müsst nicht alles mit euch machen lassen. Ja. Vermieter haben Pflichten und das ist ein absolutes Arschlochverhalten, du darfst da gar nicht in dieser Wohnung sein, vermutlich ist die Schimmelbelastung sogar noch recht hoch. Da müsste eigentlich so eine Firma wie Isotec oder sowas kommen, diese alles trockenlegen und sowas. Da muss die Feuchtigkeit ja vernünftig professionell rausgemacht werden. Das ist einfach ein Arschlochvermieter, der kein Geld in die Hand nehmen will, dir Gesundheitsrisiko aussetzt, fremde Leute, mit denen nicht kommuniziert wird mit dir. Das ist super schlimm alles. Dass du einer unverdlichen Wohnung bist, wo die Türen irgendwo rumstehen,
muss nicht passieren.
Und jetzt Achtung, mal eine Warnung für alle Introvertierten, das wird noch schlimmer.
Ich lebe also schon in dieser
Wohnung, wo alles rumsteht, du hast
es wirklich auf dem Präsentiertel,
dein ganzes erbärmliches Drecksleben da
vor dir, und dann
hatte ich einen Drehtag.
Und dann habe ich dem Vermieter geschrieben,
dem Hausmeister geschrieben, so, ja, hier ist das noch
nicht fertig. So, da standen auch die ganzen Werkzeuge
noch da und die Leiter und alles
stand noch da. Ich dachte, das ist einfach noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Und der so, ja, ich bin gerade in Italien,
so.
Und dann habe ich dem Fotos geschickt und gesagt,
das ist noch nicht abgeschlossen hier.
Und dann meinte der so, ja, okay, kümmere ich mich
drum und dann habe ich gesagt, okay, ich fahre dann und dann und dann wieder dann bin ich wieder weg dann kann da jemand rein in die wohnung und dann war drehtag und es war nachtdreh bis ich glaube wirklich vier uhr nachts oder so vier uhr nachts ich komme nach hause super müde legt mich in mein Bett Denkt mir, endlich mal in Ruhe schlafen, schlaf ein und wache auf zu, hallo, ich wache auf und ein fremder Mann steht in meinem Zimmer neben meinem Bett und sagt, hallo, ich soll hier arbeiten. und ich dachte ja klar die haben der hat den schlüssel noch ja aber du kannst doch nicht
einfach und ich habe wirklich, habe vielleicht zweieinhalb Stunden geschlafen, weil ich mir dachte, endlich kann ich mal ausschlafen. Wir werden nach zweieinhalb Stunden von so einem fucking Handwerker geweckt. Und ich habe gesagt, was, was, was, nee, nee, ich bin da noch da. Aber du verlierst doch komplett die Privatsphäre. Alter, und vor allem das Schlimmste war, diese ganzen Privatzeug, Intimsphäre, das war alles da, aber ich konnte es verdrängen, weil ich dachte mir, ich weiß ja nicht, wer das ist, der das alles macht. Und plötzlich steht dieser Mensch, der all meine Objekte, die ich je hatte, all meinen Bullshit, meinen peinlichen Kram, meine dummen Sachen, alle mal in der Hand hatte, steht jetzt vor mir, ich lieg halbnackt schlafen, steht der
schlafen vor mir, mit der für meine Verhältnisse
so viel halt geht
und dann sage ich, nee,
und dann schicke ich den
raus und
konnte den ganzen Tag auch nicht wieder einschlafen,
zweieinhalb Stunden geschlafen, absolute
Katastrophe, dass da wirklich
ein fremder Mensch in deiner Wohnung steht. Das ist ja nicht passieren, das ist ja das Schlimmste, und ich würde Miete zurückverlangen für die Zeit, in der du jetzt darunter leben musst, er kann auch nicht irgendwelche fremden Menschen bei dir reinschicken, wenn du da zu Hause bist und sagst, das geht nicht, weil ich habe ihm extra geschrieben, wann ich wieder weg bin, scheiße, aber mein Problem. Du verstehst, dass er in Italien ist, ne?
Ich verstehe, das stimmt. Was soll er machen? Er ist in Italien, der hat drei Aperol-Spritze-Indus gehört, das du ihm geschrieben hast. Natürlich wird er jetzt nicht irgendwie dann darauf hören. Ich meine. Hat man ein bisschen Verständnis? Vermieter sein ist auch schwer. Ja, und dann habe ich ihm nochmal geschrieben und habe gesagt, hier war jetzt gerade der Handwerker, der kann hier nicht arbeiten, während ich da bin. Ich bin ab dem Tag nicht mehr da.
Ab dem Tag bin ich weg, ab dem Tag kann gearbeitet werden.
Und was schreibt er zurück?
Hast du gut gemacht?
Und ich denke, was ist denn hier los eigentlich?
Ich verstehe dich nicht, er ist gerade in Italien. Was ist denn hier los? Aber er ist doch gerade in Italien. Welchem Albtraum bin ich denn hier los eigentlich? Ich verstehe dich nicht. Er ist gerade in Italien.
Was ist denn hier los?
Aber er ist doch gerade in Italien.
Welchem Albtraum bin ich denn hier gefangen? Also ist es so ein, vor allem plötzlich wird geduzt, nie wurde geduzt mit diesem Hausmeister, es war immer auf sie Basis. Ich glaube, ich habe erneut geantwortet. Hier sind Leute in meiner Wohnung, hast du gut gemacht. Ne, ich glaube, es war falscher Chat. Der Handwerker hat ihm geschrieben, alter dieser Freak mit dem Katana ist da, der Messi-Freak mit dem Katana ist da, der war im Bett für seine Verhältnisse wahrscheinlich in einer großen Morgenlatte, ich bin jetzt einfach gegangen. Und er wollte dem schreiben, ja hast du gut gemacht. Vermutlich das Beste und wahrscheinlich hat das dann dir ausgedrungen geschrieben weil du parallel geschrieben hast, der war jetzt da er kann ja nicht arbeiten die ist schon so, dass Handwerker können theoretisch arbeiten wenn du da bist klar, natürlich auch nicht das ist ja wirklich einfach die ganze Wohnung und vor allem man denkt sich so was müssen diese Leute denken, weil ich habe eine Zeit lang, glaube ich, wirklich jeden Tag so einen Sojajoghurt gegessen, so mit Kirschen, so jeden Tag.
Und ich fand das so cool, dass diese Plastikdeckel so perfekt aufeinander passen.
Und dann habe ich die einfach gesammelt.
Klar.
Und wenn du einfach jeden Tag so ein Ding isst, über Wochen und Wochen und Wochen, habe ich wirklich zwei, ich mach mal zwei so ein Meter hohe Türme
von diesen Plastikdeckeln, einfach in meiner
Küche, einfach aus Spaß.
Jetzt kommt aber jemand in meine Wohnung, baut
alles um und der nimmt diese
Türme und stellt
sie einfach in die Wohnung im Sinne von
und der denkt sich auch, was für ein
komplett wahnsinniger
Mensch lebt hier denn eigentlich
und wer bin ich, dass ich diese
Türme an Plastikdeckeln
dann irgendwo anders, ah, die stelle ich
Vielen Dank. Komplett wahnsinniger Mensch lebt hier denn eigentlich. Und wer bin ich, dass ich diese Türme an Plastikdeckeln dann irgendwo anders, ah, die stelle ich da nach, nachdem wir gestrichen haben. Was ich mir so denke, wenn ich jetzt so ein Modern Day, das Schweigen der Lämmer oder so Zodiac inszenieren müsste, die Wohnung eines Serienkillers wäre sehr wahrscheinlich so eine Wohnung, wo Unordnung und wild und dann so alte Mittelalterwaffen und dann so Alpro-Joghurt gestapelte Dinge. Ich glaube, die Handwerker denken, haben richtig Angst vor dir. Das kann auch sein. Ich glaube, du hast so Sozialcringe und was denken die von mir, denke ich bin Idiot, denke ich bin Loser. Die kamen rein, die haben richtig Schiss. Und dann bist du da in einem Bett und dann dieser alte Spruch bei Wespen. Ich glaube, er hatte mehr Angst vor dir, als du vor ihm in dem Moment. Wenn er diesen Typen sieht, der schläft. Für ihn ist das ja auch fucking unangenehm. Stell dir vor, du sagst, ja, arbeite in der Wohnung und dann schläft da jemand im Bett und du denkst, soll ich jetzt anfangen? Du hast du ja kein Bett, sondern eine Matratze auf dem Boden liegen. Also absolut furchtbar, aber natürlich, du sagst jetzt zu Recht, Mietminderung, Miete verweigern, gedönst. Aber ich habe da immer so ein bisschen dieses Restaurant-Ding. Am Ende, egal was du für dich erkämpfst und kriegst, wohnst du noch bei ihm. der spuckt in dein Essen. Aber er kann jetzt nicht in deine Wohnung spucken. Und du kannst nichts dagegen tun. Und egal, wie sehr du ... Wie soll man mehr in deine Wohnung spucken, als dass Schimmel existiert? Naja, der kann alles in der Wohnung machen. Der kann mein Kleingeld klauen, der kann alles klauen, die können alles kaputt machen, die können das irgendwie falsch aufbauen oder sagen, nein, wer in meiner Wohnung ist, das hat auch mit Gastfreundschaft zu tun, wer in meiner Wohnung ist, der wird gut behandelt, weil der hat mich einfach direkt im Herzen, der hat seine Hand um mein Herz gelegt. Und ich kann jetzt den nicht mehr ... Aber er drückt es so. Er drückt es. Ich möchte die andere Meinung einnehmen, einfach um hier einen gewissen Binnenpluralismus an den Tag zu legen und euch da draußen zu sagen, dass ihr das nicht, ihr müsst das nicht über euch ergehen lassen. Ja, anderen sage ich das ja auch. Genau. Aber ich denke mir, nee, der ist da und der ist da wirklich der Zehn-Rebell-Dosen. Vermieter sind nicht eure Gastgeber, ihr bezahlt das und seid dann da zu Hause. Das ist euer Leben und die Privatsphäre und die eigene Wohnung ist ein grosser Wert und das ist ein sehr, sehr grosser schützenswerter Wert ich bitte euch lasst das nicht über euch ergehen sondern kämpft für eure Rechte ja auch du ja kämpft für deine Rechte ich verstehe alle Punkte und ich denke mir das ist auch so unangenehm dann da irgendwelche Rechte zu erfordern und dann hast du ja immer mit dem zu tun auf der anderen Seite du musst nichts mit dem dir und dann kannst du ja wieder eine Mietminderung klagen. Ich würde eintreten, Mieterschutzbund, ich würde umziehen, Mieterschutzbund und die letzten Monatsmieten zurück verlangen. Hey, hey, hey. Ich will einfach nur, dass es vorbei ist. Meine Frage wäre denn, ist der Schimmel schon von dem Besitzer ergriffen?
Nein.
Warum zucken deine Augen so? Nein, natürlich nicht. Ich bin immer noch Florentin Well. Florentin Well. Ich bin immer noch die ganzen Magic-Karten auch so hingelegt. Aber die Leichen, die hast du wenigstens vorsorglich vorher schon von das sind so oder die buffalo buffalo bill wohnen bei schweigen der lämmer und dann und dann diese kokons da habe ich diese kokons da offen rumliegen lassen von diesen motten aber diese die todesmotte da habe ich die da aufgeklebt und so, habe ich die da liegen lassen, unangenehm. Ich bin einfach fucking Buffalo. Es ist furchtbar. Vor allem, ich glaube, Leute würden bezahlen, um in so eine Messie-Wohnung mal reinzugehen, um sich mal dieses Elend, dieses Ekel-Elend mal zu schauen. Nee, Messie ist es ja nicht. Nee, es ist einfach nur vernachlässigt, kein Selbstwertgefühl, sowas. Aber kennst du das, wenn du so einen True-Crime-Podcast hörst und dann so, ja, der Mörder hat das und das und hat die Hand abgeschnitten und so und du denkst, war ich das? Also nur so als kurzer Gedanke so, wie, kann ich das gewesen sein? Also einfach nur so der Gedanke, dass du dir, weißt du, ja, der Mörder ist immer noch auf freiem Fusse denkst du dir ich bin auf freiem Fuss ich bin auf sehr freiem Fusse gerade und der Beschäftigte ist ein weisser Mann mit dunkelbraunen schwarzen Haaren ja und dann so was hab ich weil ich denke mir so, verdrängt man so einen Mord auch irgendwie?
Also angenommen, du machst das jetzt so,
Affekt, Impuls, du bringst
irgendeinen Typen Ruheabteil um oder so,
zerstückelst den so, versuchst den in Säure
aufzulösen. Und dann hörst du
so einen True Crime Podcast und dann so
von Hagen, 12 Uhr,
moin mal, ICE 201. Ich war da drin.
Das ist ziemlich genau meine.
Ich hab den umgebracht. Das ist ziemlich genau meine. Hä, das ist doch genau der Zug, wo ich diesen Typen angebracht habe. Moment mal, und was sagen die? Er hat versucht, ihn in Säure aufzulösen, wusste aber nicht genau, welche Säure. Hä, das ist genau auch mir passiert. Hat einfach eine grosse Packung Center-Shocks in eine Tonne geworfen, hat gemerkt, dass es nicht funktioniert, wollte die Leiche dann zu Wurst verarbeiten, hat gegoogelt, wie mache ich Wurst, wusste nicht, welche Gewürze er benutzen soll. Das kommt mir alles sehr bekannt vor. Vielleicht war ich das. Ich glaube, man darf nicht unterschätzen, wie schwierig es ist, eine Leiche zu entsorgen, dass sie nicht mehr erkannt wird. Ich glaube, es ist nicht so trivial. Und deswegen, ich glaube ja immer, warum werden Mörder entdeckt, die sind dumm, dumm, dumm.
Aber ich glaube, man hinterlässt schon sehr, sehr viele Spuren. Also sorry, ich will sie niemanden auf Ideen bringen, aber mein erster Impuls bei Leiche ist immer, ins Meer. Aber du musst sie ja ins Meer bringen. Ja. Wie? Im Car to go?
Ja, miete dir den Car to go, setz ihn auf die Hinterbank, fahr einfach an die Nordsee, mitten in der Nacht.
Stopp, stopp, halt, halt, halt, halt. Setz ihn auf die Hinterbank.
Ja, ja, okay, setz ihn auf die Hinterbank.
Nee, nee, aber wo hast du ihn umgebracht?
Ja, oder wickel ihn ein in irgendwie so Klarsichtfotien, irgendwas, dass er nicht tropft oder sowas. Aber das sieht ja schon jeder, in der Großstadt geht das ja schon nicht.
Warte, bis es Nacht ist. Und deswegen ist er, du kennst ist. Es ist drei Uhr nachts. Kennst du diesen Menschen noch nicht? Ja, man lernt sich kennen. Im Laufe eines Mordes. Aber so, und dann einfach irgendwie so Steine an die Füsse binden und dann musst du halt nur einen guten Punkt finden, wenn du kein eigenes Boot hast. Du hast jetzt einen Bootsführerschein, aber dass man dann halt guckt, dass man irgendwie so einen Kai entlang fährt oder so, wo man so ein Stück... Stimmt, für Mörder ein großes Problem, Mörder würden sich ja niemals dann ein Boot ohne Bootsführerschein mieten, um die gleiche Zeit zu sorgen, weil da hätte man ja moralische Bedenken. Ja, oder eine Kreuzfahrt oder so, und dann einfach vor allem, wenn du das... Du kannst sie nicht verheimlichen, du hast einen leblosen Körper, die sind riesig,
die sind auch schwer, menschliche Körper,
die sind so eklig schwer, also glaube
ich.
Aber kannst du nicht an irgendeine Klippe
fahren oder so, also gibt es nicht irgendwo so eine,
dass du mit dem Auto halt nachts an eine
Klippe fährst. Ungesehen in Deutschland, in Deutschland ist auch kein gutes Land
zum Umbringen. Ja, in Schottland oder so, wo
so hohe Klippen, so da schmeißt
du die runter, forget it, niemals findet das.
Ja, aber in Deutschland ist viel zu dicht besiedelt und so,
und die schönen, grossen Klippen, auf die man will,
die sind ja auch dann, da sind ja Tuturi-Hotsports
und so was. Nicht nachts, Stefan, du denkst immer
nicht in der Nacht. So, du musst nachts
denken. Aber dann fährst du runter.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht so schwer. Wenn du da so einen Teppich
ziehst, das, wo Blut raussuppt.
Ja. Ja, das haben ja nur Leute gesehen.
Aber jetzt so Säure, also du wirst sie jetzt auch nicht auf Anhieb. Kannst du auch nicht so viel kaufen, glaube ich in Deutschland. Wie viel Zitronensäure oder dann irgendwie so einfach, da presst man so ein paar Zitronen aus und haut den in Zitronensaft und denkt sich, da passiert ja gar nichts. Und du guckst so ein YouTube-Video oder so Breaking Bad-Episoden und stehst dann so mit so einer Schürze in der Kiss the Chef, stehst in der Küche und presst so Zitronen aus und immer so, ah, okay. So durchnascht er ein bisschen selber. Ja, so sehe ich dich da. Also einfach Salz rein, einfach irgendwas, keine Ahnung. Und am Ende ist die Leiche richtig lecker. Und vor dir hast du so ein Simon-Backett-Buch, woraus du so gelernt hast. Ja, und du musst natürlich auch gucken mit Google, ne? Du kannst ja nicht jetzt 20 Suchanfragen hintereinander, wie löse ich eine Leiche auf, wo kann ich das kaufen, sondern du musst dir dazwischen immer nochmal Lady Gaga Lyrics oder irgendwie Lena Meyer Landrut Freund Fragezeichen, du musst dir noch ein paar Alibi Suchanfragen dazwischen packen und dann wieder, wie verarbeite ich einen Menschen zu Wurst, wie lang kann ich selber, ich glaube, selbst essen ist keine dumme Idee. Also ein Mensch einfach das Fleisch zu einer Wurst verarbeiten, Hackfleisch, ich glaube, das kriegt man nicht so unbedingt raus, und dann isst du den einfach, jeden Tag Spaghetti, Bolognese, das geht doch, das geht. Geschmacklich halt schwierig, ne? Holo Bolo? Machst du da schöne Bolognese da mit lecker Sellerie oder so? Das geht schon. Ich habe eine kleine Info für euch. Wie schnell können eure Passwörter gehackt werden? Ich wollte eine Statistik gefunden, einfach um dieses Thema jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen mal abzuhaken.
Und ich musste sehr lachen gerade, weil die Statistik heißt, time it takes a hacker to brute force your password. Also einfach alles durchprobieren. Jetzt gerade. Brute force heißt genau, es ist ein Programm, wo ganz schnell alles durchprobiert wird, mit der Technik, die man 2024 hat. zum beispiel number of characters, vier und dann nur Numbers, nur Nummern, vier Nummern, äh, eins, zwei, drei, vier zum Beispiel, oder vier, zwei, drei, eins, instantly. Sofort. Instantly. Okay. Sieben Zahlen wäre schon vier Sekunden. Vierzehn Zahlen würde schon ein Jahr dauern. Oh, okay. Achtzehn Zahlen schon elftausend Jahre. Wenn ihr einen Lowercase Letter noch reinbaut, wären es bei vier, also drei Zahlen, ein Lowercase Letter, zum Beispiel eins, zwei, drei, L, instantly. Oh, okay, immer noch instantly. Ein Lowercase, mit Lowercase Lettern und achtzehn wären es 350 Billion Years. Ohne jetzt dein Passwort zu verraten, wo findet man dein Passwort? Meins, ich habe auf jeden Fall, ich habe Nummern, uppercase und lowercase-Letters und deswegen wären es bei mir ... Ich will es nicht zeigen. Wir zählen unter dem Tisch, aber sagen's dann. Meins wäre neuntausend Jahre. Neuntausend. Ich finde auch gut in der Grafik, ich hab die auch gesehen, dass die eingeteilt ist in Rot, Orange, Grün. Das ist nämlich der spannende Part, weil vier Sekunden ist rot. Verstehe ich, weil es vier Sekunden ist. Ein Jahr ist auch rot noch. Ja dann wird's ab zwei Jahre haben sie sich überlegt, orange. Also ein Jahr, ich finde, wenn ein Jahr ein Typ an meinem Rechner sitzt, würde ich das wahrscheinlich merken.
Irgendwann würde man es merken.
Ich würde irgendwann sagen, aber irgendwas ist doch hier komisch, wer sind sie eigentlich? Ja, aber also, wenn ich jetzt Hacker bin.
Und dann aber auch spannend, 517 Millionen Jahre ist gelb. Also das wäre mir zu unsicher. 517 Millionen? Aber dann sowas wie 56 trillion years ist grün. Was Sinn ergibt. Da bin ich dann wieder dabei. Aber das ist ja nur der Worst Case, oder? Also das ist ja dann, sagenfällig. Er könnte es ja auch sofort haben. Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich nur der Durchschnitt, wie lange man durchschnittlich braucht. Aber du kannst ja Glück haben und es auch sofort machen. Aber kann ein Hacker an mehr als einem Passwort gleichzeitig arbeiten? Oder ist die Idee, dass er seine gesamte Rechenpower oder kann er auch tausende Passwörter nebeneinander laufen lassen und dann hast du eine höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit wieder? Ja, müssen wir auch mal herausfinden, das sind die ganzen Fragen, die ich jetzt auch rede zur Statistik, aber ich finde es spannend, macht euch ja mehr Gedanken. Abdeutet eure Passwörter, macht noch ein Ausrufezeichen rein, Fragezeichen oder einfach mal ein Sternchen. Ja, genau. Super, super.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Lasst, also,
ändert eure Passwörter, wenn wir eins festhalten, nach dieser Folge.
Mein Passwort.
Dehltet eure Passwörter ab, macht ein Sternchen rein
und ein Ausrufezeichen, dann,
lasst euch nicht von euren Vermietern auf der Nase rumtanzen,
ihr könnt dagegen was unternehmen.
Drittens,
Schimmel ist ungewöhnlich, trocknet eure Wände. Viertens, es wird wieder wärmer draußen, also passt ein bisschen auf, damit ihr euch nicht kaputt schwitzt. Fünftens, falls ihr einen Fernsehsender besitzt, wir haben einige tolle Ideen vorgestellt, wie weit reist es runter haben wir dabei, denn einiges könnt ihr da vielleicht noch einbauen, falls ihr möchtet.
Wir verabschieden uns, wünschen euch eine ganz, ganz schöne Woche.
Macht's gut.
Viel Spaß bei allem, was ihr macht.
Zieht euch mal eine witzige Schuhe an oder so und geht ins Freibad.
Tschüss Stefan.
Macht's gut.
Es war mir eine Freude.
Es war auch mir eine Freude. Ich hoffe, es geht bald wieder bergauf in deinem Leben.
Ja, hoffe ich auch.
Ich bin für dich da. Falls du Hilfe brauchst.
Alles klar. Macht's gut. da. Falls du Hilfe brauchst. Alles klar.
Mach's gut.
Ciao.
Ciao, mach's gut.
Wir heben auf.
It's the worst bird production.